what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we're going to be talking
about some things that are going to
happen in Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3.
come on Drax seriously dude Marvel
studioslash Disney has released some
details about the movie giving us a new
description for the movie and some
pretty good ideas about some particular
scenes that will take place during
Guardians 3. now I must warn you some
things we're going to talk about in this
video are not going to be for the faint
of heart because we have reports about
some deaths if you didn't really pick up
on that fact from the trailer it does
look like we're going to have at least
one death of one of the Guardians in
this film Pete I'm done running
so we'll be talking about that today and
we'll be talking about how Adam Warlock
and The Sovereign connect with the high
evolutionary and talking about some
particular scenes that involve Adam
Warlock and Rocket Raccoon specifically
how Adam Warlock is going to kidnap
rocket so we'll break down all of this
in today's video and also don't forget
we're doing a Marvel Legends giveaway
right now all you got to do to enter is
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment down below if you're chosen as
the winner I will announce it in a video
just be sure to look out for fake
comments of people pretending to be me
if you win I will announce it in the
video so on Disney plus there's a new
description for the Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. so this is coming straight
from Disney straight from Marvel Studios
and it says at the top Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 Peter Quill must rally his
team to defend the universe along with
protecting one of their own now this one
of their own is rocket the high
evolutionary is the villain well one of
the villains he's the main villain of
Guardians 3 and he's also the creator of
Rocket he's the one who tore him apart
and put him back together over and over
again as Rocket mentioned in the first
Guardians film rocket you're drunk all
right no one's laughing at you he thinks
up some stupid thing he does well I
didn't ask to get made
I didn't have to be torn apart and put
back together over and over and turn
into some
some little monster rocket no one's
calling you a monster and it looks like
in this film he wants him back but
moving on there is an even bigger
description under the details tab if you
click on it it says Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. in Marvel Studios is
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 our
beloved band of Misfits are looking a
bit different these days after acquiring
nowhere from The Collector we find the
Guardians working to repair the extreme
Damage Done by Thanos determined to make
nowhere a safe haven not only for
themselves but for all refugees
displaced by the harsh Universe it isn't
long before their attempt to return to
normal is appended by a brutal attack
from a new unknown enemy and Peter Still
reeling from the loss of Gamora must
rally his team around him to defend the
universe along with protecting one of
their own a mission if not completed
successfully could quite possibly lead
to the end of the Guardians as we know
them so again talking about of deaths
that last line it's pretty morbid and it
definitely shows us that the stakes are
pretty high in this one but let's go
ahead and break this thing down piece by
piece now the first part is actually
very big the Guardians of the Galaxy
purchased nowhere from The Collector now
if you watch the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special you know this although
it was only briefly mentioned but what I
really like about this is that they say
they're trying to make it a safe haven
for refugees in the universe and they're
trying to repair the Damage Done by
Thanos now we haven't really addressed
this outside of Earth we've seen a few
accounts of what has happened on Earth
with the snap people getting dusted and
then coming back we saw that happen to
Elena belova we also saw it happen to
Monaco Rambo we've seen the chaos on
Earth but we have yet to see it anywhere
outside of Earth NOW Thor love and
thunder could have done it but nothing
about the snap was really mentioned and
the cool part here about them taking
over nowhere is that they're Now
official they are the official Guardians
of the Galaxy this is their title and
their job they are truly looking after
the Galaxy creating a safe haven for
everybody and we saw them decide to take
on their title and provide Universal
Protection and 411 Thunder then the
Guardians split up with Thor so the
Guardians could go answer many distress
signals now it's many years later James
Gunn has actually confirmed this and
said that Thor was only with the
Guardians for a few weeks which means
Thor lost all of that weight in just a
few weeks which is pretty crazy but you
know he's the god of thunder so the
Guardians of the Galaxy now are truly
the Guardians of the Galaxy not really a
band of Misfits anymore but here's where
it gets juicy it says it isn't long
before their attempt to return to normal
is appended by a brutal attack from a
new unknown enemy this is out of warlock
because if they were attacked by the
high evolutionary rocket would have
known who he was so it wouldn't be an
unknown enemy so this is clearly Adam
Warlock now here's the thing we know
that the Sovereign and specifically
Aisha created Adam Morlock she created
him to destroy the guardians but judging
from what we saw in the trailer it does
look like rocket gets kidnapped and he
ends up in the hands of the high
evolutionary once again and let me
explain just how I think this is going
to happen the Guardians of the Galaxy
get attacked at nowhere by Adam Warlock
and from here Adam Warlock actually
takes rocket back to the high
evolutionary the only question about
that is why Aisha is the one who wanted
Rocket Raccoon why would Adam Warlock
take him back to the high evolutionary
and that answer I believe is because
they actually needed the high
evolutionary to Perfect Adam in the
post-credits of Guardians 2 we learned
that Adam's cocoon was new this type of
person that Aisha was creating is a
totally new thing that they were doing
so one could easily see how she wouldn't
be able to perfect it but could go to
the high evolutionary because he is
known for genetic Evolution he
experiments on subjects and advances
them genetically if there's an expert
out there on Evolution and trying to
create a perfect being it is the high
evolutionary so so I believe that Aisha
goes to the high evolutionary to help
him Perfect Adam Warlock I am assuming
that he is going to ask why she wants
Adam Warlock to be made and I'm assuming
as well that she'll tell him to go
destroy the Guardians of the Galaxy in
which she will mention that Rocket
Raccoon is a part of it because she
hates rocket for stealing the batteries
that's where the high evolutionary will
become sort of aware of Rocket Raccoon
again remember rocket escaped from the
high evolutionary so here's where I
think a deal gets made the high
evolutionary says that he will Perfect
Adam Warlock but in return Adam must
deliver rocket to him Aisha would
probably accept this because she knows
that he'll probably torture Rocket
Raccoon which is what she'll probably
want this is where the final line comes
in where it says a mission if not
completed successfully could quite
possibly lead to the end of the
Guardians as we know them I believe this
is because Rocket Raccoon gets kidnapped
and is about to be killed and if they
don't complete this Mission a rescue
mission he'll die and the Guardians will
never be the same all also a scene that
backs this up is the scene from the
trailer where Rocket says I'm done
running this could be because the high
evolutionary keeps trying to attack them
or it could be when the Guardians
actually end up rescuing rocket in that
scene we can see the background is on
fire there's a lot of chaos and
destruction behind them so they clearly
just fought most likely to protect
Rockets since this description says
twice that the Guardians have to protect
one of their own so it looks like Adam
Warlock is going to be attacking the
Guardians of the Galaxy at now their
home base nowhere he's going to defeat
them probably pretty easily and then
take rocket from there the Guardians
will search for him and that's where I
think Gamora gets involved nebula could
have heard of the high evolutionary
before and she could say that possibly
Gamora knows where she is so they could
try to locate Gamora or since nowhere is
now a safe haven perhaps Gamora simply
shows up at nowhere and even though
Gamora doesn't really have a huge
connection to the Guardians at this
point nebula still is her sister and
she's clearly a better sister in this
timeline than the one that she she had
in the other so perhaps that's why
she'll feel compelled to help her
sister's family that is kind of her
family so I think that the Guardians
will end up finding rocket they'll end
up rescuing him but then they're gonna
take the fight to him because if they
don't then he's just going to keep
searching for Rocket over and over and
over again until rocket eventually dies
and speaking of deaths there's been a
report recently and I will give you a
spoiler alert right now if you don't
want to hear it click away there's been
a report recently from Alex over the
cosmic circus that Drax will die now I
don't particularly like this because I
feel like we didn't get much more of a
story about his wife and his daughter
there was a rumor going around a while
ago that his daughter and his wife
weren't actually dead and that he could
quite possibly run into them in
Guardians 3. however that was just a
rumor and is not confirmed in any way
but we do know that this is going to be
the final installment of the Guardians
of the Galaxy Trilogy from James Gunn
and he's probably gonna go out with a
bang even Palm clementiff recently said
that this film it doesn't mean that it's
over over over but it is going to be
different moving forward which basically
means deaths we could have some retire
but based off of what James Gunn has
been known to do in some of his films
I'm assuming we're going to get one or
two or maybe even more deaths and that
is going to be super super sad so rap at
least Drax if this is true but hey let
me know what you think about these plot
points in the comments down below what
do you think about the plot so far in my
theories let me know in the comments
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and for live updates you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf